welcome to pi data 2021
we're here with
scale wooding
skel is a computer engineer and math
mathematician who splits his time
between scientific computing research
and attacking grand challenges he is a
part-time researcher at the
tute institute and the co-founder of
learn leap labs
a firm focused on the challenges that
organizations face in mixing people and
technology
and since this is his time i'll let him
take off thank you stephen yeah my name
is uh shel wooding i um uh i'm a lot of
things as you heard in that bio i'm an
engineer a
computer engineer an entrepreneur a
researcher
i'm a parent and right now i am basking
in the glow of the middle of the pacific
ocean uh so i wanted to thank you first
of all all of you who joined us today
live uh for hanging out till the very
end of today's session
uh to the last talk uh the last time
slot because it's probably the last time
zone that anybody is hanging out in so
uh so thank you very much and for those
of you who are going to be joining later
on on a recorded video in a time which
is much more convenient for your time
zone i completely understand thank you
for coming anyway all right so let's get
started today i'm going to be talking
about makefiles but
let's modify that a bit i'm going to be
talking about
workflows
i'm going to be talking about how to go
about building a better workflow around
your data science processes in
particular i'm going to focus down on
one thing which is how to make your data
science environments
reproducible
all right because i think that's pretty
much the key to getting anything done i
know for me as a parent it's absolutely
the key to getting anything done because
when i was
younger and i didn't have little kids
running around the house i had what was
called a working memory which meant i
could put something down pick it up six
hours later and still remember what had
been going on i no longer have that
which means i have to rely on tools like
workflow and processes to keep myself
productive so today we're going to be
talking about workflows and processes
and i'm going to start out with a claim
where if there's only one thing that you
take away from today's talk it is going
to be this point and my claim is is that
workflow good workflow trumps tooling
every time
because if you have good workflow you
can tend to sweep a lot of details
associated with the tooling under the
rug you can even change your tools and
you don't necessarily have to
change your workflow so today's talk is
going to be about building a better data
science workflow to help make your
environments more reproducible
all right and as if to hammer home the
point that i'm not too concerned about
which tools you're actually using i'm
going to do this today building a better
workflow using a tool that was
originally written in the 70s so let's
flash back in time for a second
we're going to be using make to make our
workflows a little bit better and the
reason i've chosen this particular tool
is not just to illustrate a point
it's because the designers of make
actually did some really really clever
things when they sat down to make this
tool now make was originally intended
for software developers and it was a
tool to help them build workflows out of
a whole bunch of files they had lying
around where one file depends on another
file depends on another file and when
you go ahead and modify something you
want those dependencies to sort of flow
through a workflow well they're building
workflows of make i'm going to build
more clothes with make but the design
decisions i really like about make and
the reason i want to bring it to your
attention today are as follows one it
has a really really simple file format
okay this is great
a good simple file format means that we
can go ahead and check that thing in the
get which is going to be important later
on
all right two make is all about bundling
things up into sub commands so we're
going to be able to take a bunch of
potentially complex behavior and bundle
up under a very easy sub command like
make create environment
okay
three because make was about making
software
it has the ability to specify
dependencies and that's super important
when you're building a workflow because
the fact that a it has to get done
before b happens is basically the whole
definition of what workflow means do
this then do that and make was built
with all of this stuff in mind but my
absolute favorite thing about make as a
utility is it just has a great name
people talk about the developer
experience well talk about a tool where
if i want to make something i just
literally type the command make
something that is great dx all right
enough about the past let's jump back to
the future for a second
if you would like to follow along on
today's talk there's two ways that you
can do it and the first is go ahead and
clone that repo there
github.com hackalog that's me make
better defaults and in that repo you're
going to find a number of the files that
i'm going to be talking about today i'm
going to be mentioning these files but
i'm not going to be throwing the
contents of them up on the screen
because one the screen isn't that big
and two i don't think that would be
interesting in a half hour talk
so i highly recommend you clone this
repo and then just follow along at your
leisure and look at the pieces of code
that i'm talking about
but
potentially even better than cloning
that and following along that repo up
there was generated using a cookie
cutter tool called easy data and in two
days from now the very last tutorial as
a matter of fact of pi data global uh
amy wooding who happens to be my partner
in crime my partner in reproducibility
research and my partner in life is going
to be giving a tutorial on reproducible
data science using easy data it's going
to be great it's going to touch on all
the stuff i talk about today but a whole
bunch more so i highly recommend you
check it out it's the last tutorial of
pi data global this year
all right so let's start out with a
series of tips and then talk about how
we can work those tips into a concrete
workflow using git the first tip i'm
going to start out really easy is
something that all of you already know
i'm sure and that is if you want a
reproducible workflow of any kind always
use revision control i highly recommend
you use get
i'm not going to talk anything more
about this because everything i say from
now on is going to assume that you are
using git to check all of your various
pieces of your workflow into
what i am going to talk a lot about
though is tip number two which is always
if you're doing python development if
you're doing data science with python if
you're involving pythons in any way
always use a virtual environment now it
doesn't matter if your system has a
totally reasonable version of python on
it it doesn't matter if your system has
a totally unreasonable version of python
on it don't
use it i always want you when you're
starting any kind of work with python to
think about using a virtual environment
so what do i mean by that if you don't
already use python virtual environments
the good news is there's lots of choose
lots to choose from bad news is there's
lots to choose from and so you've got to
make some decisions there me personally
i use conda for my for my virtual
environments now you don't have to
there's other choices there's there's
pip end there's a poetry there's
virtualenv uh and then there's any
number of wrappers that have built on
top of each one of these tools to solve
some of the limitations of those
particular tools and i will warn you all
of those tools have limitations they're
all very good at some things but they're
all a little less good i will say at
other things and so
one of the things we're going to be
doing with make and working on our
workflow today is overcoming some of the
limitations in the tools that we have
all right
by the way we're talking about building
a good workflow in this talk what do i
even mean by that well i'm going to use
a very very simple dish uh definition of
this of this idea here today and to me a
good reproducible data science workflow
is one that it means that i don't have
to remember
anything i don't have to remember things
i don't have to have a working memory
because as mentioned earlier one i don't
and two uh it just gets in the way so
whenever i sit down at a keyboard muscle
memory can take over and i can just go
without having to actually know what i
was doing uh last time i sat down so as
we go through this tutorial good
workflow simply means i don't have to
remember stuff
so let's get started say we're going to
sit down right now and do some data
science what's the first thing you do
well flashing back a second ago to tip
number two we're going to use a virtual
environment so i use conda let's sit
down and conda activate
some kind of environment right i'm doing
data science so hey why don't activate
an environment called data science that
sounds convenient that sounds totally
reasonable i can load up an environment
called data science with all of my data
science tools and then i'm ready to go
whenever i want to do some work
problem is this is actually a terrible
terrible idea
and here's why because if i create one
environment data science that i then use
for a bunch of different projects i have
used what i would call a monolithic
virtual environment one environment to
rule them all one environment that has
all sorts of dependencies throughout the
different projects that i'm working on
and that is not a good thing from a
reproducibility perspective
why
well here's a typical use case i'm
sitting down i'm doing some work i
decide oh i need a library that i don't
currently have i need to use umap oh i
know i'll just conda install umap learn
and
well for those of you in the crowd who
do use conda you might be familiar with
this process you go and kind of install
something and it's checking dependencies
it's checking dependencies
it's checking dependencies it's checking
dependencies for a really long time why
because you have a conflict turns out
there's something that you've got
installed that can't possibly coexist
with the thing that you want to install
and after about 15 minutes condo will
return from this process and say hey
couldn't install it here's a totally
unintelligible list of reasons why
now you could debug that but i've found
in practice me and most of my colleagues
don't debug that instead we go to
a little technique we call pep we just
pip install cond install didn't work ah
i know i will pip install and nine times
out of ten that actually does the trick
the problem is we have just introduced a
major potential reproducibility
nightmare
because the reason that pip was able to
successfully install something that
maybe condo wasn't is because somewhere
along the line either pip got it right
and conden didn't which in the days of
condo forge isn't always that that
common more likely pip went and ignored
some of the actual dependencies
something that it couldn't satisfy it
just didn't and you know what things are
probably going to work okay
for using umap for doing something else
you have potentially broken a dependency
that you need on your system
if you use monolithic environments
whenever you go ahead and install
something new you're potentially
breaking some other work that you're
going to be doing later and the problem
with this is that other work you're not
going to notice this breakage until you
sit down and do that that could be six
months from now you're not going to
remember you installed umap you're not
going to remember that that was the
moment that things stopped working
because you wouldn't have known
this is a reproducibility problem so you
don't want to do that
so tip number three is we always want to
make sure we're using one virtual
environment for every project that we
work on if you use git number one
then we can very very simply come up
with a rule of thumb which is you want
to make sure you don't use monolithic
virtual environments always use an
environment named after the git repo
you're working in
all right this automatically satisfies
the tips so far you're using git
you're using one environment uh per git
repo and you don't have to remember
anything
that's cool
all right
moving along
tip number four
i want you to always check in your
virtual environments so so far we've
gone through the go through the list so
far we've used we're using yet that's
cool we're using a virtual alignment
that's cool we're only using one virtual
environment and we're naming it after a
git repo that's very cool well since
we're already naming it there why don't
we just stick it in the git repo and
keep all the details of what our
environment is going to be right there
with the code
perfect that's what we're going to do
and now we get to the point in our talk
where you realize that i have already
been lying to you because at the outset
i said i'm a guy who uses conduct
and that's actually not strictly true i
actually use a wrapper called conda n
which is cool it ships with conda it's
always there
that's good um but i use that because
conda has some limitations that i don't
particularly like i love working with
conda because it lets me pick my version
of python it lets me have my pick my my
channels where my con environments are
living in
but truth is when i'm doing data science
work i also often have to use pip too
and
n and in particular the file format that
it likes to use this environment.yaml
lets me do that it lets me specify not
just which version of python not just
where where the channels are coming from
not just my conda dependencies but also
my pip
dependencies and even if you're somebody
who doesn't necessarily use any projects
that use pip one of the really cool
things that pip can do for you is let
you create editable source modules you
can have a setup.pi or right in your
directory and you can be working on a
module and using it through notebooks as
you do the software development now i'm
not going to go into this today but i do
recommend if this sounds cool to you you
come back in two days the last tutorial
of the conference
and sit in on amy's reproducible data
science with easy data tutorial
okay so environment.yaml is a way for us
to specify what we want in our python
environment and then check that file in
to get
cool
all right and so now we get down to five
now we get down to the meat of things
now that we have
started using git made sure that we're
using virtual environment manager
written down those requirements in a
file format which is nice and easy to
parse with yet checked it into our repo
now we're ready to script our workflow
and this is the thing that i do with
make
and with make files
and here's how that works if you've
cloned the repo if you're following
along you look in that directory you're
going to see a make file and the make
file itself is actually pretty small
this is it right here but that's because
it's hiding a little bit of the logic in
these other three things make file
include make file ends and make file
help and i'll tell you right now most of
the workflow stuff is hidden that middle
file makefile dot ends
and what that
workflow does is really simple it gives
you an easy way to create
to update and to delete your contact
environments
so by using that little makefile my
project my workflow boils down to three
very simple things whenever i sit down
at the keyboard if i've just cloned this
project for the very first time then i
can do a make create environment and
it'll actually create my conda
environment for me from scratch from the
stuff that's checked into the repo then
i can just con to activate make better
defaults or whatever git environment i
happen to be working
with and then i do a make update
environment now
i'm going to have to apologize to really
get into the thick and the weeds of
things it seems like i've created the
environment i've activated the
environment and i've updated the
environment that seems like so there's
an extra step in here but there is one
slight problem with using a tool that
was originally written in 1976 and that
it doesn't quite work
entirely with this workflow i would love
if i could do a make activate
environment but i can't because make
doesn't let me do that it doesn't let me
have side effects in the shell that i'm
currently running in so this is my
compromise and this is what my workflow
looks like
all right so we're going to come back to
why this stuff is important as we go
through the rest of the tips for today
tip number six is actually more of a
warning than a tip all right and that is
that if you're going to follow along if
you're going to do this process if
you're going to script your makefile
creation if you're going to go through
the process or the trouble of checking
in your environment definition to your
git repo
then never ever ever
install a package manually please
don't type conda install anything don't
type pip install anything you've got a
file environment.yml where you specify
what you want in your environment please
edit that now don't worry you don't have
to use emacs you could use another
editor i don't know why you would but
you could
but make sure that you edit that
environment.yaml and that's the file
that you end up using
all right and then when you're done
editing that and adding a requirement
say you map learn into that file then go
ahead and type make update environment
what have you done here you've made sure
that the environment definition you have
checked into your repo is always the
right one all right don't add things
manually because as soon as soon as you
do that you have potentially added
things which are not recorded in that
source code repository and that is not
reproducible
i'm going to talk about a couple of
other cute little things that i do in
this make file it's not just about oh
well you scripted the creating the
environment how often do i do that
there's other things that you can do
with make that that may help your
your data science process
one of them is just a cute trick all
right i'm going to say you should use
automatic documentation
all right automatic documentation is
documentation that's really really close
to the code at hand
all right the problem with maintaining
documentation is if your documentation
is sitting in another file somewhere i
guarantee you 100 of the time it is
already out of date the trick to keeping
your documentation up to date um
and accurate is keeping it as close to
your actual code as possible right this
is why jupiter notebooks are awesome
because jupiter notebooks have a bunch
of exposition and then they have the
code then they have a bunch of
exposition and then they have the code
and because they're right next to each
other you feel silly if one of those
things is actually wrong when you
actually edit it when you change your
code or you do most of the time
in this workflow process i'm setting up
here i wanted to make sure that it was a
good process a good workflow and by that
you don't have to remember things and so
in that process i included a magical
little script that does uh automatic
documentation
automatic documentation is all up in
that file over there that make file.help
file
and what it's going to do for you is
this if you clone this repo any repo
that i've created using easy data or any
similar thing
and you don't know where to get started
just type
make
okay just type make
by typing make it's going to by default
give you a help message now that's not
unusual lots of things give you a help
message if you just give up the command
but this help message is generated
entirely from the make file itself that
is the stuff and the code that you've
checked in to do your workflow is going
to document itself right it's going to
remind you if you've forgotten how to
get started to make create environment
activate the right environment which is
written right up there
and then updated
it's going to tell you some of the
details about your system like your
project name like the architecture you
haven't been working on and most
importantly it's going to give you a
list of all of the available sub
commands that correspond to your
workflow all right i've already talked
about a few of them uh make create
environment update environment delete
environment but there's one that i want
to draw your attention to which is clean
which says delete all compiled python
files this is something i added just for
this particular project
that i happen to be working on and if
you look in the make file you see it's
defined right there and all it does is
clean out all python craft
but the documentation that showed up on
that screen here
is actually just from a comment and then
just by adding a comment with those two
hash marks in front that says delete all
compiled files before that target that's
going to be included in that default
help message so you can create your
workflows in make just put a little
comment in the makefile right next to
the target itself probably going to be
easier to maintain than writing out
somewhere else and that's automatically
going to be documented it's a super cute
trick it's a little ugly the way that
it's been implemented but go ahead check
out the makefile that help
to see how that works i think that
should be a default behavior in make
period
one other thing
i said off the top that i use condo and
i do use khan i love condo but conda is
not perfect no
far
far
far from it
tip number seven is if you really want a
truly reproducible workflow it's
important when you're defining your
environments to separate what you want
from what you need
and record both of those things a much
simpler way of saying this particular
tip
is use
lock files
now if you've ever used something like
pip end you know what a lock file is
if you haven't it's a way of separating
the libraries that i actually want to
use from the libraries that i end up
installing because as you all well know
a python library typically has a lot of
other python libraries as dependencies
which also have a lot of other python
libraries as dependencies
and by the time you add one dependency
in your project you've probably got 200
different packages installed
now if you're concerned at all about the
reproducibility of your work you want to
write down which packages got installed
and you want to know when something
changes but you don't want to have to
maintain a giant list of all 200 things
that went into making your one library
dependency work you don't really want to
think about that unless you need to and
that's what this separation idea is all
about now conda doesn't have log files
all right but that's okay because i've
already scripted my workflow so i'm just
going to keep going with this and add
some ability to do the equivalent of a
log file in that make file directly and
i'm going to hide it into the workflow
i've already got into the make create
environment or make update environment
so that if i actually make any changes
to that environment the ammo file which
is the file describing what i want
installed
it will go ahead compute all the
necessary dependencies save those out
and i what i actually need file which is
this horribly long named thing and make
sure that it is there for me check
enable in to get so that i can do this
all right so i have in effect hacked
lock files into condo without ever
touching conduct itself simply by using
this make dog check of course that's not
the only way to solve the problem in
fact there are projects out there which
solve the problem i just found out out
about one a couple of weeks ago called
condo lock cool
you can go ahead and use that and you
can slide it into your workflow and the
nice thing about using a makefile to
hide all this complexity
is that you're never going to notice any
difference to your workflow whether
you've implemented it yourself whether
your tool implements it or whether
you're using some other third-party
library to do it
okay we're coming near the end of this
little set of tips about making your
environment reproducible
this is one of my favorite things about
reproducibility reproducibility means i
can take the sigourney weaver approach
to debugging things
by that i mean well you have to have
seen aliens but if you've seen aliens
you know if you have a bug problem if
you have an infestation if you have an
environment which is somehow messed up
because maybe you accidentally type pip
install whatever whatever
you can fix that the old-fashioned way
the guaranteed 100 percent gonna solve
the problem way you can take off you can
nuke the site from orbit
it's the only way to be sure
you can delete your environment and you
can delete your environment with
confidence uh especially if you think
it's somehow gotten messed up because
everything is reproducible you're using
git you're using virtual environments
you're writing that specification down
storing it in the get environment you've
scripted away all the creation process
you don't even remember how to have to
do that you can just type the sequence
of commands which if you've forgotten
are given to you by default and when you
type the make command
and all is going to be
well
and that
i claim
is a good workflow because that is a
workflow which leads me through a
process where i don't have to remember
things and it leads me through a process
where things are reproducible
all right
so what have we done
we've taken some core workflow ideas and
we have swept a lot of the details of
the tooling we used to implement those
under the rug we started out by using
git
i'm sure everybody here does already
after this talk i want to hear that
everybody and some more are using git to
check in their data science work
you're always using
virtual environments you're not using a
system python even happens to be the one
that you like today because it won't be
the one that you like tomorrow
you're using one environment per project
one virtual environment for git repo and
since you don't want to have to remember
things you're just going to simply name
it after that repository
you're going to then write down what you
need in your environment and check that
in to get
and script your workflow process using
make or whatever other tool that you
think is appropriate for the job so that
you don't need to remember anything
you're going to remember don't install
things manually make sure you use that
scripted environment that you have very
very carefully created
and you're going to separate your
definition of what you want from what
actually gets installed by using
lock files
in short you're going to build
reproducible environments
and that
is my talk for the day so thank you very
much for your attention if you're here
in person um bless you if you're
watching this after the fact so it's
actually reasonable in your time zone
thank you so much for coming and
remember if you are interested in
reproducibility in data science please
come back two days from now for amy's
tutorial it is going to be fantastic
thank you for your attention mahalo
oh definitely thank you for the talk
anyone have any questions we have a few
minutes
and i can tell the uh the audience
one audience member definitely really
feels the effort you put in this is
awesome this is a really hardcore
instance of wanting to work from a
single
source of truth
that
so yeah
it looks like probably black magic to a
lot of people right
the thing about black magic is you don't
want to you don't want to know what goes
on in the kitchen your favorite
restaurant sweep that stuff under the
road
all right all right uh if you have any
time for questions we looks like we
are starting to come in there's
definitely one question there the
dennis's question uh when you manually
edit your environment you have a file is
there a risk of introducing version
compatibilities there absolutely is and
this is um
because you don't have you don't control
you don't control how people specify
their version dependencies so just
because you want to use package and
packet b doesn't mean those two people
get along in terms of what their
requirements are
but this is one of the reasons you want
to use log files and separate the things
you actually need for what you're doing
from the things that actually get
installed because if you can restrict
sort of your limitations on the
environment to the absolute minimal
things if you're saying well i need umap
and i need hdb scan but i don't care
about anything else just make it work
that's great and the fact that you're
not sharing this environment with any
other project means that the possibility
of you having a conflict is greatly
greatly reduced
the other cool thing that you can do is
if you do have a conflict and this does
occasionally happen like i do
occasionally find that i have to
manually pin a version of something
because they have a bug or something
else is i can
record the reasons for that version pin
in that environment yeah i'm going to
file with a comment i can say oh this is
because of bug number 74 in this git
repo
and then later on if something comes up
if i add a new package and it conflicts
with that one i can go back to their uh
their reboot i can check if that bug's
gotten fixed and eliminate that
particular version pin and that usually
fixes my problem so the answer is yes
you may introduce version
incompatibilities but as long as you're
sort of following along with those other
tips you're going to be able to minimize
the chance that anything is going to
happen to you
it looks like he's satisfied with the
response that makes a lot of sense and
addresses the biggest pain point i've
had with cond environments
so thanks for that black files for the
win
thank you too dennis
all right
all right uh
anything else you'd like to add to that
i think it's all good we'll see you all
in two days
all right
last one of the conference
double and triple thanks to the speaker
and all
and all the attendees
you all have a wonderful day ah i'll add
this one point somebody was asking me
about what i used to do this talk it's a
little tool called impossible to say but
easier to spell
mmhm check them out it's pretty cool